savez-vous comment Louis Lumière a eu
l'idée du cinématographe ou comment
alfred hchkock est devenu le roi du
suspense si vous êtes un passionné de 7e
mars cette case du calendrier de l'avant
de tv78 devrait vous
[Musique]
intéresser l'histoire du cinéma pour les
nuls n'y voyez aucune offense mais avec
cet ouvrage vous deviendrez incollable
sur le sujet ciné des origines à nos
jours et c'est un versaillais qui signe
ce livre Vincent Mirabel ce professeur
de cinéma est une véritable encyclopédie
vivante sur la thématique une histoire
riche et en image qu'il vous compte avec
plein d'anecdotes drôles parfois
cocasses et souvent méconnu du grand
public vous saurez tout des révolutions
techniques et des bouleversements
artistiques avec ce livre réédité en
2017 aux éditions First c'est garanti
vous ne serez plus nul et vous pourrez
surtout briller dans vos soirées en
famille ou entre
amis euh wilfri tu mets pas dans le
bêtisier ça